hi everyone it's me danny ceo i'm
backstage at the drew barrymore show
right now and if you just watched drew
and myself make a really delicious
plant-based orange cheesecake
she mentioned we also can do something
with the orange peels
i'm going to show you how to upcycle
behind the scenes right now in backstage
so first and foremost guys if you blink
you'll miss it
this is a jar got a jar and you fill it
with orange peel so save your orange
peels eat the oranges your kids love
oranges just save the peels on the
inside
all you have to do is fill it all the
way up with white vinegar
and what we're creating is an
all-purpose citrus cleaner
and we're going to let this marinate for
seven days
and for seven days i'll show you what it
looks like later this is what it looks
like you have this beautiful
rich colored all-cleaning all-purpose
cleaning solution
the oranges have infused our natural
citrus oils
into the vinegar so you have the
disinfecting power of the vinegar you've
got the grease
cutting power of the natural citrus oils
transfer it to a spray bottle
look at this i have a little demo here
and look at this
it really does a fantastic job come on
yeah i've got one more that i want to
show you and this is
a diy what i call a soft scrubby
mixture that you're gonna make so this
is what we're making and it's a great
thing for
kitchen counter tops and for bathrooms
and what you need
is baking soda cause steel soap so we
have one cup of baking soda
half a cup of castile soap and that's
like that
soap you find that's super concentrated
in that big bottle and then a little
hydrogen peroxide so what we have here
are three
powerhouse ingredients the hydrogen
peroxide is a natural disinfectant
we've got the castile soap that's the
soap we need to cut through grease
and then we have the baking soda that's
the grit that's the scrubby part
that you need you're almost making like
this frosting you see it
just mix it all together such a great
thing to do with kids
because everything's gonna bubble up and
you learn a little about chemistry
and then with the oranges you just grate
a little bit of the peel right into the
mixture it's almost like an orange
frosting
but don't eat it mix it all together and
instantly it starts to get thicker and
thicker and thicker
and i'll show you what i do that you
transfer it to a jar just like this
and this is quite dirty but i'll show
you if you take
a little bit of this on a dirty kitchen
countertop or something
it really does break everything away
and look it looks like magic doesn't it
instant soft scrub instant all natural
cleaner
couldn't be any easier backstage bye
[Music]
everyone
you